claude blanchemaison bonjour merci
d'être avec nous ce matin alors les
difficultés de nikol pashinian on les a
vus est ce qu'elle vous semble
insurmontable
il est dans une situation très très
compliqué puisque vous savez il a été
élu avec une forte majorité il ya deux
ans à la suite de toute une période de
manifestations contre le président
rencontre le premier sarkissian et donc
il a été lu sur as tu un journaliste qui
était le leader de l'opposition et il
est élu sur un programme de
modernisation économique mais aussi un
programme nationaliste bien sûr alors il
se retrouve aujourd'hui un petit peu à
contre emploi puisque dans le fond la la
la la tacc de l'azerbaïdjan il faut bien
appeler les choses par leur nom pour
recouvrer son territoire autour du
nagorny karabakh est peut-être le
dégrader karabakh lui-même la mettre un
chef de guerre et en tant que chef de
guerre il a promis à son peuple
dans le fond de se défendre et de gagner
contre l'azerbaïdjan or il ne pouvait
pas gagner puisque le déséquilibre est
devenu très important le territoire qui
avait été gagné
owni garder karabakh et autour du
nagorny karabakh
après la guerre qui s'est terminée en 94
refléter une certaine situation mais 26
ans plus tard la situation est très très
différentes
l'azerbaïdjan est une sorte de petro et
a en réalité qui a les ressources
considérables du fait de son pétrole et
qui est maintenant d'une certaine
manière sur arm et par conséquent le
président lincoln pas de signal pardon
le premier ministre y colle pas de
chicane à la plus grande difficulté à
expliquer à son peuple pourquoi il a été
battu alors que l'autre blanche raison
pourquoi le président aliev bien le
continue à être si belliqueux
le président aliyev évidemment estime
avoir le
poupe il a d'ailleurs organisé une sorte
de 18,2 défilé de la victoire à bakou où
il a invité le président erdogan et tous
les deux se sont réjouis de la victoire
et se sont même ton même tenu des propos
encore plus belliqueux pour dire que la
guerre n'était pas terminée malgré le
cessez le feu et que en effet
l'azerbaïdjan veut recouvrer la totalité
de la souveraineté sur ledit garni
karabakh
ce soutien cure que change la donne
parce que l'azerbaïdjan a bénéficié d'un
soutien militaire important des armes
tueur probablement aussi des officiers
d'état-major turc et bien entendu ils
estiment avoir le vent en poupe alors le
cessez le feu qui est une sorte
d'armistice comporte aussi un gain très
important pour l'azerbaïdjan qui est ce
couloir qui a été tracée au sud de
l'arménie et qui permet d'avoir une
route de liaison directe entre un
territoire azéri qui se trouvait séparer
géographiquement de l'azerbaïdjan c'est
là kitsch et mad et ce couloir va être
garanti et la circulation et sera
garantie par les forces de gardes
frontières du fsb russe pendant la durée
de l'accord c'est à dire cinq ans
renouvelables donc effectivement
l'azerbaïdjan qui estiment appartenir à
la zone culturelle de la turquie se sont
confortées à l'heure actuelle ce sens le
vent en poupe
bien que l'accord d'armistice ne lui
permettent pas de patrouiller sur la
zone de contact et ni sur la route du
cordon ombilical de latchine qui relie
l'arménie à ce qui reste du nagorny
karabakh
ni sur la route sans la route du sud qui
sera garanti par les troupes de maintien
de la paix de la russie alors est ce que
ça veut dire qu'on s'amuse on s'achemine
vers une sortie de la crise entre azéri
et arménien pas tout de suite pas si sûr
parce que la réconciliation est
évidemment très difficile
elle devrait passer par une négociation
entre l'arménie et la turquie pour que
l'arménie et la turquie normalisent
leurs relations et retrouve des
relations apaisées
là c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour en
parler et une tentative dans le passé en
effet de réconciliation entre la turquie
et l'arménie
mais il ya beaucoup d'obstacles il ya
naturellement d'abord le fait que
l'arménie évoque très souvent le le
génocide qui a eu lieu en 1915 en
arménie en turquie et que par conséquent
ceci est un obstacle important et puis
maintenant effectivement la modification
territoriale qui vient d'intervenir est
également sans doute un obstacle bien
que personne ne conteste que ce
territoire et est du territoire azéri du
point de vue du droit international
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison je
rappelle que vous êtes expert
international pour rt france